欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们 这一节课我们来讲一下关于国际站的三大流量场景
让我们的产品自然流量暴增
这些位置一定要抢占
因为这是店铺的战略
很多时候我们店铺没有流量
或者是说我们店铺处在一个流量的瓶颈
实时不能突破
或者是说我们的直动车成本一直降不下来
都是因为缺少这三个板块的流量
才会导致我们直动车成本高
同时我们店铺的质量流量少
以及我们单品的一个循环量少的一个原因
所以我们一定要重视这三大板块
因为这三大板块被很多人忽视了
而且他们以为这三大板块的流量是很小的
其实这三大板块是在国际站的首页
PC端的首页
所以说它的整体的总流量是非常大的
我们一定要把这三大板块重视起来
那么第一个大流量场景是什么呢
就是榜单这个场景
榜单里面它会有好评榜
销榜还有热门榜
它有三个榜单
那么这三个分别对应的规则是不一样的
比如说好评榜
它是近90天内
有两条评价都在4星以上的产品
才有资格进入这个好评榜
但是是否能够拿得到流量呢
还要看我们的排名
也就是你这个产品在近90天内的评论数
能不能排在前20名
如果你能持续的排在前20名
甚至更加靠前的位置
那么你得到的流量将会是更多
但是如果你排名很靠后面
也是没有流量的
第二个就是热销榜单
这是针对RTS产品的
也就是在近90天内产生过销量
也有支付的订单
那么它的排序规则是按照近90天内
订单量的前20名
一定要有排名才能够获得流量
所以说为什么很多人
它的产品进入榜单了
但是它不能是一直在榜单
因为它有一个时间
维度近90天内
它是一个动态变化的数据
所以你的产品有时候能进入榜单
有时候不能进入榜单
它是每天实时更新的
第三个就是热门榜单
也就是近90天内
询盘要大于等于1才有资格
同时呢
你的近90天的询盘要排在前20名
才能够真正的进入这个榜单
并且获得流量
你的排名越靠前
那么获得流量的概率就越大
那么第二大流量场景
就是新品这个板块
它的条件就是
你的产品要在90天内发布
同时你的访客要大于等于1
同时是非重复铺品
也就是同时满足这三个条件
之后
你的产品只要在满足下面任何一个条件
就能够实现进入这个板块
第一个就是商品成长分要大于75分
且30天内搜索曝光点击率大于2%
且30天内有商机
商机就包括寻盘
定达这三个
所以这里就有三个条件
一个是75分
同时2点击率
同时有商机就这几个维度
那么如果你达不到第一个条件
那么你就要达成第二个条件
进30天搜索曝光量大于20个
同时呢
进30天搜索曝光率大于4%
也就是你的搜索点击率
也大于等于4%
那么只要符合这个条件
也是可以成功的进入这个大流量的场景
第三个大流量场景就是会采购
这个条件就比较苛刻
需要你是精品的商家
同时你的RTS品在近180天内
是最低价的
活动期间也至少要达9折
这个才能够去报名
才能够通过
第三个条件就是商品的支付转化率
位于所属的二级或者叶子内幕的
百分之二十
前百分之二十
一定要满足这个三个条件的产品
才能去
一个是报名
报名了之后
如果你符合条件了就能够通过
通过了之后
你就会进入会采购榜单
进行一个千人千面和数据沉淀去匹配
去给更多的买家展示
才能够获得更多的流量
如果你报名的产品效果本来很差
或者是说你报名的产品本身数据很少
即使它通过报名了
但是它依然是很难获得流量的
所以这个板块
建议你去报名那些数据很好
并且比较有市场需求的产品类型
这个板块才能够获得更多的流量
最后面我们一定要记住
充分的理解规则
然后利用规则
把店铺里面的优质产品
全部按照规则的指标去提升
紧紧的盯住我们的目标
把具体的事情做到位了
那么这个店铺拿到好成绩
一定是必然的
接下来我们到后台去看一下
具体的一个操作
首先我们打开这个后台
就到了这个板块
也就是流量参谋
再到我们的流量助手这个板块
这里就有三大流量场景
你看这些都有具体的入场规则
我们刚刚已经讲了
这里面这个就是展示它的一个效果
这些效果都是比较直观的
我们都可以反馈出
我们现在这个店铺的整体效果怎么样
同时呢我们还可以通过这个榜单
查看被目热门品
然后选择我们具体的细分的内幕
再看一下当前整个市场上
哪些的产品是更加受到欢迎的
我们可以参考这些去选款
选属性选风格等等都可以
另外一个就是这里我们可以看到
我们店铺里面有哪些产品
是已经进入过榜单了
这些产品我们要去看一下
现在还在不在榜单
或者是说现在它缺什么数据
我们要去给它们补充一些数据
去提升它们的整体的效果
这样我们就能够捉得住重点产品
来提升它的效果
让我们店铺效果更好
那么另一个呢
就是我们要去看店铺里面的潜力的产品
也就是哪些产品有接近榜单的幼为的标准
那么我们按照这个潜力品去挖掘一些新的产品
去补充巡盘或者是绑定订单
做访客营销
EDM营销
做优惠活动
直播
把这些产品挖上去
那么这些都是有机会增加我们这个产品进入榜单的一个机会
所以我们要经常来这里浏览一下看一下这些产品
去选一下这些产品去推广啊
或者是说关注一下我们店铺重点要扶持的产品是哪些
那么我们把资源时间精力都花在那些比较有潜力的产品上面
那么我们得到的回报肯定是比你普遍傻网
或者是到处去选品啊选不对这些产品
放推广的效果来得更加的直接
更加的有效
其他的两个板块
比如说新品板块
或者是说这个会采购板块
他们的维度都是一样的
我们都可以在这里参考去选择产品
或者是去判断一些产品是否有效
那么这个板块就讲到这里
具体的我们需要去理解规则
利用规则选到好的产品
扶持好的产品
去打造
另外一个如果你想知道你的这几个板块
它的每个月的流量变化有没有增长的话
那么我们可以在这个流量参谋这里去看流量来源
这些流量来源你就能够找得到
你所做的动作是不是有效的
如果你做的动作有效
那么它在这些板块都是会有数据重现的
你看这些都是会有数据重现的
如果没有效果就像这个店铺一样
这些都是没有数据的
所以大家一定要重视这个三大板块流量场景的获得
因为这些板块都是免费的流量
而且能够给你的店铺带来突破性的增长
同时能够大大的降低你获取寻盘的成本
联赏你直通车无效推广浪费预算的这种情况
好了
这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见